[تصفيق]
الرئيس البولندي روسيا تستخدم النوويه في
اوكرانيا ولكن هناك ما هو اخطر بكثير
والغرب يتحضر لضربه نوويه ضد موسكو فما
الذي يجري ومدفد في يعلن ما تحتاجه
اوكرانيا لاجل السلام وكياف تعلن تقديم
التنازلات
يجري مجزره اقاله لقاده جيشه وبعد تصاعد
التوترات رئيس بيلاروسيا يفاجئ بولندا
بقرار جديد والاف الجنود الروسيه تحدون
الغرب من القطب الشمالي وبريطانيا ترد
بتحضير 900 جندي اوكراني للمواجهه وايكو
اسطحشود الجيوش وما بين التدخل فن جروال
حل الدبلوماسي شعر كم يطور سلاحه النووي
بطريقه مرعبه للغربيين واليمن ينجو من
كارثه مروعه على البحر
الحرب تاخذ منحا اخر
ما ان ينتهي الحديث عنها حتى تجذب العالم
نحوها من جديد ليحبس الناس انفاسهم ويضع
الجميع يده على قلبه وخوفه رعبا عن الحرب
النوويه نتحدث ولكن هناك ما هو اعظم من
النووي يا ساده فها هو الرئيس البولندي
يصرح لصحيفه واشنطن بوست انه لا يرجح ان
تلجا روسيا الى استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
في اوكرانيا مشيرا الى وجود تهديد اكثر
خطوره والذي يتمثل في الاشكاليات المحيطه
بمحطات الطاقه النوويه وعلى المدى القصير
حصلت بعض الهجمات على هذه المحطه مهدده
بكارثه عالميه غير مسبوقه وقبل ثلاثه ايام
بالتحديد تصدت الدفاعات الروسيه لطائره
مسيره اوكرانيه في مدينه انرجودار حيث
كانت تتجه نحو محطه زابوريجيا الكهر ذريه
برايكم
المسيره ستستهدف المحطه يبدو لامرا مرعبا
مجرد التفكير فقط بتفجير هناك في المحطه
النوويه دعونا نكمل اخبارنا وعلى ذكر نووي
اكد نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
ان حلف الناتو يتدرب على شان ضربه النوويه
ضد روسيا بمشاركه دول غير نوويه واضاف ان
بولندا بدات جوله جديده من الاستعدادات
العسكريه بدوافع غير حقيقيه مشيرا الى ان
روسيا وبيلاروسيا قادرتان على الرد بالمثل
على اي خطوات عدائيه لياتي الحل الجذري من
روسيا هذه المره حيث اعتبر
الرئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي ان ما
تحتاجه اوكرانيا حقا هو الاستسلام الذي قد
يفتح الطريق الى السلام لكن واشنطن لا
تريد لذلك وفق قوله ليرد وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني ديمتري كوليبا معربا عن
استعداد صحيفه الاسبانيه لننتقل الى
اوكرانيا حيث احدث الرئيس الاوكراني مجزره
اقاله اقادته العسكريين وذلك باعلانه
اقاله جميع رؤساء مراكز التجنيد العسكري
في اوكرانيا من مناصبهم على خلفيه مخاوف
تتعلق بالفساد وخبر مهم كهذا بالتاكيد
يحتاج الى مصدر علينا
رؤساء مراكز التجنيد العسكري في اوكرانيا
من مناصبهم وذلك على خلفيه مخاوف تتعلق
بانتشار الفساد في صفوف الجيش الاوكراني
هذا فيما اعلنت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
ان روسيا اطلقت اربعه صواريخ فرط صوتيه من
طراز على مطار عسكري تم اعتراض صاروخ واحد
منها على الجانب الاخر اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه استهداف قاعده للمرتزقه الاجانب
في مدينه كما اشارت الى ان الخسائر الجيش
الاوكراني بلغت 50075
جنديا خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه والمصدر
هو من يتحدثك العاده المتحدث باسم سلاح
الجو الاوكراني
اطلقت اربعه صواريخ في اتجاه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه تمثلت في احدى المطارات
العسكريه التي تقع في ضواحي هذه المدينه
بيان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه هو استهداف
الجيش الروسي لما وصفه
بنقطه انتشار مؤقته للقوات المرتزقه في
منطقه صفروجيا لكن القوات الروسيه قالت
بانها تمكنت خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه من تحيد
اكثر من
575 عسكري اوكراني في غضون ذلك تم استئناف
العمل في مطار فونو كوفا بشكل طبيعي بعدما
تم اغلاقه لفتره وجيزه بسبب وجود طائره
مسيره في اجواء العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
وكان مسؤول الروسي اعلن ان الدفاعات
الجويه دمرت طائرتين اوكراني مسيرتين عند
اقترابهما من مدينه كورساك فهيالي
اوكرانيا التي لا تكلوا ولا تمل من مهاجمه
موسكو بمسيره يتم تدميرها دائما
لكن فخلال ذلك اندلع حريق في مستودع ببلده
تقع غربيه موسكو قرب المقر الرسمي للرئيس
فلاديمير ولم توضح خدمه الطوارئ سببا
اندلاع الحريق الذي امتد لمساحه الفين متر
مربع فهل اشعلت مسيرتكاب هذا الحريق الرد
الروسي لم يتاخر حيث قال فيتالي كوفان
رئيس الاداره الاقليميه في مقاطعه ريفني
الاوكرانيه ان مسيرات الروسيه استهدفت
مستودعا لتخزين النفط في المقاطعه الواقعه
غربي البلاد ما ادى الى تدميره بشكل كامل
ليس ذلك فحسب بل دوت انفجارات عنيفه في
العاصمه كياب وعدد من المدن الاخرى مع
اعلان حاله التاهب الجوي في انحاء
اوكرانيا وهنا ينتقل الروس الى القطب
الشمالي حيث تجري القوات الروسيه مناورات
عسكريه
وسط النطاق بمشاركه ثمانيه الاف جندي من
وحدات عسكريه مختلفه في المناورات التي
تستمر عده ايام في رساله تحدي روسيه واضحه
للغرب في المقابل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه تدريب 900 جنديا اوكراني من
سلاح البحريه على تنفيذ قارات تستهدف
السواحل وعمليات في البر والبحر تاتي خطوه
في اطار برنامج يتولاه الجيش البريطاني
بدعم من الشركاء الدوليين بهدف مساعده
اوكرانيا على تطوير قواتها البحريه والى
بيلاروسيا ورغم التوترات المتصاعده بين
بيلاروسيا وبولندا والتي وصلت حد نشر الاف
الجنود من كلا الطرفين على حدودهما فاجا
رئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر جميع بقرار غير
متوقع حيث اعلن لوكاشينكو انه امر حكومته
باستئناف التواصل مع بولندا في ظل التوتر
المخيم على الحدود بين البلدين
والانقسام في المواقف حيال الحرب في
اوكرانيا بحسب وكاله بيلتا الرسميه اي ان
لوكاشينكو يفضل الحوار اولا وقبل اي شيء
الاحداث والتطورات اكد البيان الختامي
لقمه الايكوس عزم دول المجموعه على ابقاء
كل الخيارات مطروحه على الطاوله لحل
الازمه في النيجر سلميا كما طالب بتفعيل
القوات الاحتياطيه للمجموعه على الفور
نقلت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه عن رئيس
اعطت الضوء الاخضر للتدخل العسكري في
النيجر في اقرب وقت ممكن بينما حذرت روسيا
من اي تدخل عسكري في النيجر قائله انه
سيزعزع الاستقرار بقوه في المنطقه ونقلت
الاوس عن مسؤولين غربيين قولهم ان قاده
الانقلاب هددوا بقتل الرئيس المحتز اذا
تدخل الدول الجوار عسكريا لتستمر التوترات
بالتصاعد فالى اين المصير قال تقرير صادر
عن الامم المتحده ان كوريا الشماليه
مستمره في تطوير سلاحها النووي في انتهاك
للقرارات الدوليه وقال
التقريب مونكيان تواصل سرقه العملات
الرقميه لتمويل برنامجها النووي وخاصه
صواريخها البالستيه اعلنت الامم المتحده
اكتمال سحب النفط من الناقله صافر قباله
اليمن وتعدي هذه الخطوه تفادي كارثه بيئيه
وانسانيه هائله كان محو اثارها سيكلف 20
مليار دولار بعد متابعه الاحداث الاخيره
في النيجر برايكم هل اقتربت الحرب اكثر من
الدوله الافريقيه
[موسيقى]